[Music]
all right let's get started everybody
who thinks this is like a big talk about
artificial intelligence like no there's
not a single robot video in here but
this is absolutely about bias trust and
doing good so it's been really really
interesting uh path for me i came from a
liberal arts degree
i did a psychology degree and then i did
as i mentioned a phd in artificial
intelligence
and uh actually and what i mentioned was
i was a programmer professionally paid
off my undergraduate debts then did a
phd in artificial intelligence because i
wanted to do science i wanted to
understand how brains worked but also i
was suddenly at mit with a psychology
degree right
and i figured out that my uh competitive
advantage was i did systems engineering
and so my phd is actually making more
human-like intelligence making it easier
to build human-like intelligence so
that's how i got where i am
and so
this this talk is going to be not about
that this talk is going to actually be
about the answers that we've got in the
last few years so in the last 10 years
or so actually it was the british in
2010 that found they put together the
first
national level soft law about the ethics
of artificial intelligence
um it was called the uh the epsrc
principles of robotics in fact they're
still talking about robots a lot then um
so we'll talk about that in a minute
actually uh so since then i've been
increasingly called on to do policy and
now i'm finally a professor of policy so
that's my new job
and so that's what i'm going to talk
about now what what what it is the
science that's underlying the policy
that we're recommending and the policy
we're doing
all right okay let's do this thing
okay so a starting point of this talk is
that ethics isn't just fluff it isn't
just discourse although discourse is
really important that's what we're here
for um but it's the way we hold our
society together now one of the things i
just saw i was i don't know if you guys
were with churchland there was a
fantastic argument about what
consciousness was because for one of the
philosophers it was exactly it meant
it's what you're aware of
right and for another one it was you
know the psychological phenomena and so
they were at loggerheads for that reason
right so there are other definitions of
ethics but this is the one i'm going to
be using it's every means by which we
hold our society together okay
so
it's a form of policy and it can be
improved with
social with with scientific
understanding that's the the posture
that i'm bringing to you
okay ai is not an enormous exception a
lot of people are saying everything has
changed i don't think it's just because
of artificial intelligence although a
lot has changed but i think actually
more of it's about the digital
revolution
but we had similar revolutions with
other technologies before and so that's
what you're going to see a lot in this
first 45 minutes is we're going to talk
a bit about how this relates to previous
revolutions and how we can learn from
those
okay
so as such
ai it's an extension of the way we
communicate and the way we think and as
such it folds into how we govern it is
both one of the things we will be using
to govern and also one of the things we
now have to deal with and govern okay
we are making interesting progress and
updating our ethics because of the fact
that we've learned things about
artificial intelligence and by that i
would include some of the discussions
we've had earlier today about democracy
right
so we know more about democracy when we
see how it's changed when you throw in
digital right that tells us what some of
the problems are
okay
so this is i mentioned before the the
british principles of robotics they're
remarkably similar to these okay these
are the oecd slash g20 principles of ai
now
the um the g20 didn't sign up to
everything the oecd did but notice who's
in the g20 china so these are things
that china has agreed as well as um you
know the oecd is pretty much like the eu
plus a few other people
so that's the uh so
the ai should be benefit people and the
planet by driving inclusive growth
sustainable development and well-being
right
ai should be designed in a way that
respects the rule of law human rights
democratic values and diversity
and they should include appropriate
safeguards for example enabling human
intervention where necessary to ensure a
fair and just society
okay there should be transparency and
responsible disclosure around ai systems
to ensure that people understand when
they are engaging with them that's
totally confusing i will tell you they
mean when people are engaging with
artificial intelligence systems hey
french
the french are the chairs of the oecd
anyway
ai systems must function in a robust
secure and safe way throughout their
lifetimes and potential risks should be
continually assessed and managed this is
one of the great innovations uh recently
of uh eu regulations that uh you have to
have your systems have to be cyber
secure for their expected lifetime you
can't just have people hacking into them
like if you buy a light bulb or
something and anyway
i could go on forever about everything
sorry about that organizations and
individuals developing deploying or
operating ai systems should be held
accountable for proper functioning in
line with the above principles all right
in in the in the british version of this
what we said was that the owner of the
robot should be attributed just like
with a car you've got to know who it is
that's responsible for its operation and
this is
in general these are similar to the
british principles but expanded and
more rooted in human rights and
sustainability but but very otherwise
very similar
okay
so what are these about
they're about being human-centered just
transparent safe and accountable those
are the five core concepts and so we've
got these we've got all these countries
signed up to do it
and we've also got the 17 un sustainable
development goals and now i'm actually
again this is unbelievable i was in
germany for five months and they
nominated me to the global partnership
for ai okay
so this thing which is basically g7 plus
interesting editions including india
isn't that um
everything we do we have to show that it
complies with the oecd principles and
the and the sustainable developing goals
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas